exprese 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 3 4 5 7 en
notación científica recordemos lo que es
la notación científica la anotación
científica es un número x una potencia
de 10
el número debe ser mayor o igual a 1 y
menor que 10
y menor que 10 debemos poner el número
principal en general es el primer número
distinto de 0
este es el primer número distinto de 0
con el que debemos comenzar este es el
único número que pondremos antes de la
coma escribimos
3,457
457 y lo debemos multiplicar por 10
elevado a algo pensemos por qué número
lo debemos multiplicar para transformar
el 3 4 5 7 en este número pequeñísimo
debemos mover la coma para transformar
3,457 debemos mover la coma hacia la
izquierda muchos espacios debemos
agregar muchos ceros a la izquierda del
debemos seguir moviendo la coma hacia la
izquierda
básicamente debemos achicar mucho el
número no podemos multiplicar por una
potencia positiva de 10 debemos
multiplicar por una potencia negativa de
10 debemos dividir por una potencia
positiva de 10 al mover un exponente
hacia la izquierda estamos dividiendo
por 10 que es lo mismo que multiplicar
10 elevado a menos 1
qué es lo mismo que multiplicar 10
elevado a menos 1 explicaré con un
ejemplo
1 por 10 claramente es 10 1 por 10
elevado a menos 1 es igual a 1
por 1 / 10 o sea 1 / 10 lo escribiré
como decimal pero me salte un paso
pondré 1 por 10 elevado a cero para que
quede más claro
este es uno por 10 elevado
a 0
este es uno por 10 elevado a 11 por 10
elevado a menos 1 es igual a 1 / 10 o
sea 0 11 por 10 elevado a menos 2 10
elevado a menos 2 es 1 / 10 al cuadrado
o 1 dividido por 100 este es uno
dividido por 100 o sea 001 que ocurre
cuando elevamos una potencia negativa lo
eleve a menos 1 básicamente movimos la
coma desde la derecha del 1 hacia la
izquierda del 1 la móvil desde acá hacia
allá al elevarlo a menos 2 la movemos
dos espacios hacia la izquierda cuantas
veces debemos moverla hacia la izquierda
para que nos dé este número contemos los
ceros que hay
debemos
debemos moverla una vez solo para que
quede antes del 3 y debemos moverla a
todas esas veces para pasar todos esos
ceros la debemos mover una vez para el 3
empezamos aquí
uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete
ocho nueve diez veces entonces será tres
cuatro cinco siete por 10 elevado a
menos 10 lo escribiré 3,45 7 por 10
elevado a menos 10 en general debemos
buscar el primer número distinto de cero
recuerden que debe estar entre 1 y 10
puede ser igual a 1 pero debe ser menor
que 10 3.457 definitivamente cumple con
eso está entre 1 y 10 y luego debemos
contar la cantidad de ceros que hay
entre la coma y el número el número
inclusive porque así sabremos cuántas
veces debemos mover la coma para obtener
este número debemos mover la coma 10
veces para obtener este número de arriba